when I see people playing brass monkey
they start engaging with each other you
can tell it just makes people happy I'm
Chris Allen I'm Rebecca Allen and we're
both cofounders of em fer at five along
with Dominic architetto one of our
biggest products is brass monkey brass
monkeys a technology that turns your
smartphone into a game controller until
they power all of these different
devices that we're using on a regular
basis and it's a Texan a really simple
thing what they do is highly complex but
what it means to us and you know as a
company it's very simple know a lot of
our time were spent engaged with our
friends and family on our mobile device
and one of the philosophies do we have
is pulling people out of using their
phone in that kind of way and actually
making it to that they're focusing
together on another screen that's out
there watching people play brass monkey
is just it's particularly the
collaborative games is really
entertaining because you can see how
everyone is working together on a single
initiative and it's really fun it's
almost like a spectator sport it's easy
to think of it as just a tablet and or a
laptop but there's this other mode which
is awesome especially for demoing stuff
it was pretty cool because you just
popped it up in ezel mode and people are
coming by and they're able to try out
big games right there it made it really
beautiful in terms of the design of it
it's really exciting you know the types
of experiences you can create with this
with this incredible
you